nehmen sie in den irak hier um meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer mode review heute am abend und
zwar von einer extrem simple
modifikation und zwar der pumpkin
crafting kkw der pumpkin carving
modifikation für minecraft 1 punkt 7.10
benötigt ford relativ simpel zu
installieren ich habe übrigens jetzt
auch mein komplettes minecraft neu
aufgesetzt alles gelöscht alles wird und
jetzt läuft wieder jetzt jetzt läuft
flüssig als ich neben 30 fps auf
deswegen sieht es bei euch vielleicht
noch ein bisschen glücklich aus aber ich
hole mir auch endlich beim neuen pc aber
ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach
direkt mit der vorstellung
das einzige was sie dafür brauchen das
einmal dass wir hier oben pumpkin
eingeben oder halt wenn jetzt auf
deutsch kürbis dann seht ihr hier schon
pumpkin building blocks an carlo
hühnchen dann schaute hierbei
dekorations blog einfach nach einer
fackel und ihr könnt hier und mal den
werkzeugen einfach keine chance nehmen
also eine schere und dann haben wir
jetzt diesen pumpkin er sieht im
inventar schon ein bisschen anders aus
ich setzte ihn als einfach mal hin
halbiert haben ganz normalen fahren kann
was er gesehen und als ich auf die
schere geklickt habe unter hingucke dann
wie sieht das ganze an und meine schere
habe ich quasi nicht mehr in der hand
also das sieht dann quasi einfach so aus
deswegen wenn ich das so immer so mache
dann ist das eventuell so ein bisschen
so besser so sagt augenkrebs augenkrebs
antrieb
irgendwann später jedenfalls kann ich
dann halt da drauf gucken und dann
einfach rechtsweg gedrückt halten dann
kann ich hier einfach mal so eine kleine
form in das ding hier rein stützen das
kann ich entweder machen indem ich das
ganze gedrückt hat und runterziehen oder
einfach immer einzelne klicks hier mache
und dann kann ich da so ein bisschen was
rein schlitzen in den kürbis natürlich
das ganze ist eine app die hab ich mir
gedacht ich stell dir euch vor weil das
ganze etwas mit halloween zu tun hat und
zwar ist ja in ein paar tagen halloween
also am 31
also in fünf tagen wenn ihr das video
seht und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
wenn ich auch wie hier gerade mal etwas
kräfte dann wird das ganze natürlich
auch ein bisschen was mit halloween zu
tun haben und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich mache einfach einen kleinen
eine kleine rakete für halloween wisst
ihr
und dann kann man das ganze auf jeden
fall schon mal so stehen lassen keinen
spaß also eigentlich ist als echter dazu
da dass man sich wirklich einfach ein
kürbis hinsetzt man nimmt eine schere in
der hand man macht irgendwie so
vielleicht dann macht man irgendwie noch
so ein bisschen und dann kommt ihr dann
seine nase dran oder kommt hier
irgendwie sowas in die richtung so ein
kleiner mund so ein bisschen wie halt
echt wie solche teile halt sonst immer
aussehen diese kürbisse da mach ich die
nase noch ein bisschen so dass sie halt
auch ausgefüllt ist die augen hettich
echten mir ein bisschen mehr mühe mit
geben können wo sich das dann am ende
irgendwie aus also links ist echt mehr
mit halloween zu verbinden als diese
raketen rechts rakete aber jedenfalls
habe ich auch gesehen
du stehst auf dem falschen geht doch
hühnchen ja
endlich respektiert wir haben hütchen
plage die welt schicken spd also was ich
einfach zeigen wollte es ist eine ganz
ganz simple modifikationen ich hab ich
ja gesagt ich liebe simple sachen wohnen
nicht ganz viele zugefügt sondern
einfach irgendwie eine sache die ganz
witzig ist und ganz cooles auch man kann
eine torchlight stecken und dann ist das
ganze beleuchtet und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal filmset leider gäbe
dann seht ihr schon das ganze strahlt
auch helligkeit aus und wenn ich jetzt
wieder richtig drauf machen dann fliegt
die fackel halt wieder raus ich bekomme
die hier als ich muss da nicht so ein
komisches jack o lantern basteln und
hier sieht das ganze auch dann
dementsprechend kann witzig aus und ist
auch ganz cool und ich denke dass man
echt coole sachen machen kann einen link
dazu es in der beschreibung das video
ist jetzt sehr sehr kurz ich denke so 34
minuten allerhöchstens aber ich denke es
ist eine ganz coole sache und damit kann
man eventuell sogar auf servern ganz
coole sachen auch desire hd denke teils
ein bisschen dran blieb das ganze für
server ausgelegt ist aber eventuell kann
auch noch ein paar runden das ist jetzt
nicht so schwer aber es ist auf jeden
fall richtig cool und seine welt in
minecraft mal so ein bisschen halloween
poppig zumal wenn es euch gefallen hat
und euch solche modifikationen gefallen
dann würde ich mich freuen wenn eine
bewertung da las und eventuell in die
kommentare schreiben welche
modifikationen eventuell für den winter
ganz gut geeignet ist und dann mach ich
mal demnächst öfter smart vorstellungen
und es tut mir leid dass in letzter zeit
zum beispiel vor ein paar tagen einmal
gar kein video kam dann irgendwann
kommen dann wieder zwei drei videos
einem tag es ist alles ruhig bin ja
umgezogen alles ist noch ein bisschen
neu für mich und ich muss gucken wie
studien und alles möglich unter einen
hut kriege
deswegen würde ich sagen sehen wir uns
dann erst mal einem anderen video wieder
zu
respektiere die reiniger rakete
halleluja